the world ends
the last words man utters
are somewhere in a lab a guy goes
it worked
that was jon stewart on the late show
with stephen colbert last month
contemplating well the end of the world
the pandemic has brought new attention
to the types of unlikely but
possibly catastrophic dangers that
usually go
ignored one of them is hiding right
under the surface of one of america's
most picturesque spots
as brook silva braga reports
yellowstone america's first national
park
is probably best known as a place for
bison to graze
or for tourists to photograph but to
michael poland it's something to study
he's the head of the yellowstone volcano
observatory
there have been some epically big
eruptions and some of them not so long
in
the geologic past the steam vents
and mud pots and all those geysers more
geysers than the rest of the world
combined
are reminders that in the distant past
yellowstone unleashed
three world altering eruptions the big
one
was about 2.1 million years ago and
that's this purple
outline here the outline of the eruption
is so big it stretches out of the park
and into idaho where we met
volcanologist madison meyers
so we come to places like this because
we could sample and know where we are
kind of in an eruptive sequence
that's the lower part that's probably
earlier
that's the upper part that was later we
had that big volcano in iceland a few
years ago we remember
oh yeah the volcanic cloud has closed
the skies over the uk
the netherlands scandinavia and northern
france and germany
how many times bigger is that one oh
like probably four thousand times bigger
the scale of that potential destruction
is why yellowstone means
yet something else to brian walsh what's
the sort of really unlikely but
potentially catastrophic outcome
if a bunch of bad things all happen at
once walsh's 2019
book end times argues we should think
more seriously about
very unlikely but potentially world
ending dangers
the table of contents reads like a
hollywood pitch meeting
i'm just calling up to tell you
something terrible has happened
warning of the accidental nuclear war of
dr strangelove
the asteroid impact of armageddon it's
what we call a global killer
even the unwelcome visitors of men in
black
does the alien invasion concern you well
i wouldn't say it concerns me as much as
some of those other risks but if it did
happen we'd be screwed
they would be so much more advanced than
we are but human advances warrior
ii the threat of climate change or a
bioengineered supervirus
or ai-powered robot soldiers are we just
scared of things that are new or do we
think this is a moment of particular
peril no we're absolutely in a moment of
unique and growing existential peril
because of our own efforts we actually
are in more danger than we ever have
been before
so walsh wants more funding for
technology that might actually help our
odds of survival
like the catalina sky survey which looks
for nearby asteroids
and how often do you find them all the
time we uh
last year we found over 1500 new
near-earth asteroids
eric christensen runs the nasa-funded
effort
i hate to ask you the popcorn movie
question but do we think we could do
anything about it
even if there was one coming the answer
may surprise you
and the answer is yes there's already an
effort to try it on a non-threatening
asteroid
nasa with help from johns hopkins
university plans to make an intercept
next year sending a spacecraft and just
ramming into the asteroid it's a little
crude
but it's effective if that sounds less
dramatic than the film version
the united states government just has to
save the world
michael poland can relate
his exact job got the movie treatment in
2004.
scientist in charge of the yellowstone
volcano observatory
the bbc film super volcano envisioned
mass volcanic devastation
that starts yes at yellowstone
have you seen the super volcano movie i
have
and it's entertaining
was fun when i wasn't in this job
but now his job includes explaining that
yellowstone is in no condition to erupt
in any of our lifetimes and when i say
no there's not any sign that the volcano
is
oftentimes people say to me that's
exactly what the guy in the movie said
yeah of course it's a movie in fact
poland's takeaway from our current
struggle with a
very bad but not world ending pandemic
is that blockbuster style dangers might
just be distractions
i guess i worry more about a volcanic
eruption that's a little lower on the
scale but still massive
those sorts of eruptions are much more
likely to happen on human life skills
or a small asteroid impact or a pandemic
that's
frankly not so dissimilar from what we
just lived through we don't tend to
focus on those because they're not maybe
as
as sexy in terms of their their
devastation
but they're much more likely to happen
and they will have global impacts
[Music]
on our visit to yellowstone there were
no super eruptions or
giant asteroids or nuclear detonations
but if the flickering thought of the end
of the world helped us appreciate the
scenery a little bit more
there was no harm in that for cbs this
morning saturday brook silva braga
yellowstone national park
beautiful now if the eruption happened
to yellowstone a lot of other smaller
things would happen before so you
would get some indication that something
is going on really do you think
is that what you learned on your your
yellowstone visit i learned something
yeah
i got in but yes enjoy the moment
right enjoy the moment is sort of the
takeaway i got because we live in a
world of
risk and danger live in the moment
that's right we like that elaine
very zen all right thank you